but we begin with more of our
remembrance of a civil rights icon
tributes are pouring in for democratic
congressman john lewis of georgia the
son of a sharecropper
who would help lead this country's march
to voter and racial equality
he lost his battle with pancreatic
cancer on friday
lewis grew up in the segregated south
and inspired by the words of dr martin
luther king jr
was drawn to the civil rights movement
he helped organize the march on
washington in 1963 and was a keynote
speaker
the day king delivered his i have a
dream speech lewis
was brutally attacked by alabama state
troopers two years later when
leading marchers in a voting rights
protest across the edmund pettus bridge
more on john lewis's extraordinary life
now from nicole killian
lewis was the youngest leader of the
civil rights movement
and it's enduring storyteller he helped
organize the march on washington
in august 1963 we do not want our
freedom
gradually but we want to be free now
two years later lewis led a march from
selma
to montgomery alabama we are marching to
our state capitol to dramatize to our
nation and to the world
our determination to win first-class
citizenship
that ended abruptly at the foot of the
edmond pettis bridge
over the course of his life lewis was
arrested more than 45 times
all for what he called good trouble
elected to congress from an atlanta
district in 1986
he pushed for civil rights gay rights
and boycotted two republican
presidential
he inaugurations a living reminder of
the legacy
of the civil rights movement when people
tell me nothing has changed
i just feel like saying come and walk in
my shoes i will show you
i would take you to those places john
lewis was
80 years old
president trump did not immediately
comment on the death of congressman
lewis but there has been an
outpouring of condolences in and around
washington from former president bill
clinton who called
lewis a giant to congressional leaders
like house speaker nancy pelosi who said
he was an american hero and of course
you may recall
a few weeks ago d.c muriel bowser gave
lewis a tour
of black lives matter plaza right
outside of the white house here
she praised him as the conscience of our
nation
michelle and pictures taken there
that will be ones to watch nicole thank
you so much